you're watching the daily climate show
on sky news
on today's programme a promise that
november's climate summit will be the
most inclusive cop
yet as the government reveals the main
themes for the meeting
slow progress on fast fashion 250 of the
world's biggest brands and retailers are
criticized
for not being open enough about their
environmental practices
and how a new type of tire could help
cut
air pollution and microplastics
[Music]
hello and welcome to the uk's only daily
climate news show where we track the
changes happening to our world right now
and meet those coming up with the
solutions now in glasgow in november a
12-day summit will take place
and the decisions that are made there
will affect the future of the whole
planet
world leaders activists business
representatives and scientists will all
be attending
cop 26 the most important climate
meeting
in six years and today we heard the
government's latest ambitions
for that summit young people will
interview government ministers on stage
as part of plans to make cop 26 the most
inclusive ever
while other themes include nature gender
adaptation
and cities well boris johnson has been
questioned by
mps today about the government's plans
for cop our chief political
correspondent john craig was listening
so john what did he say more questions
than answers really
quite techy exchanges between the prime
minister and
indeed particularly some conservative
mps on the committee philip dunn
caroline knox and tom tougenhart in
particular
he was asked how the government intended
to meet all its pledges
on climate change he was even asked by
caroline knox
how is the cop summit going to be gender
specific he kept stressing however on
measures to tackle climate change that
he was determined to keep
bills low for energy consumers this is a
government
determined to keep bills low he said at
one point
eco-friendly heat pumps he said cost ten
thousand pounds
that's a lot of money for ordinary
people he said
uh it was uh pretty pretty spiky and
spicy at times
at one point tom tugan are no love lost
there
said i'm interested in your answers to
my questions
not ones that you wish i had asked he
said
so we didn't learn much specifically
from the prime minister there
and it was all a bit awkward and a bit
spicy
john thank you let's take a look now at
the day's other climate news and
campaigners want the uk
to invest in new technologies to recover
raw materials from
e-waste a new study by the
not-for-profit organization
material focus suggests 379
000 kilograms of materials like gold
silver and platinum
are found each year in electricals which
have been thrown away
rather than recycled it estimates a
proportion of these metals worth at
least
13 million pounds can't be retrieved
through the uk's existing
mining processes a river in the lake
district will be
re-wiggled to reduce flooding and
restore
wildlife populations the national trust
has begun work to recreate a series of
bends and smaller channels in gold real
back
which has been straightened over
hundreds of years it's hoped that this
will
slow the flow of water downstream and
reconnect the river with a flood plain
allowing the wider landscape to absorb
the water
the woodland trust says it will phase
out using plastic tree guards at its
sites by the end of this year in an
effort to be more sustainable
the charity have been trialling a wide
range of plastic-free alternatives
including cardboard and wool
to see how effective they are tree
guards are used to prevent
deer and rabbits from grazing on
saplings in the early stages of growth
and a french company has developed a
robot that eats
rubbish from the sea the electric
powered boat called the jellyfish bot
uses a net to collect plastic bottles
bags and other waste found in harbours
that human cleaners can't reach it's
already in operation in 15 french ports
and is being exported to
singapore japan and norway
more than a hundred billion pieces of
clothing are made
every year around the world and the
fashion industry is responsible
for around 10 percent of global
emissions
but it can be really hard to know what
shops are doing to protect the
environment or
improve their sustainability the fashion
transparency index ranks 250 of the
world's largest brands and retailers
and in a moment we'll be hearing about
their latest findings
but first here's your guide to fast
fashion in 60 seconds
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
well let's bring in sarah ditty global
policy director at fashion revolution
an activism movement founded after the
rana plaza factory collapse
in 2013. sarah ditty hello to you
the impact of fast fashion is being
talked about more isn't it but
how much are big brands doing to try to
reduce
their environmental impact
well overall the standout finding of the
fashion transparency index this year is
that the world's biggest fashion brands
are moving too
slowly on transparency and that needs to
change
especially when it comes to really
important issues such as textile waste
carbon emissions and fair pay for
workers in the supply chain and i think
it's important to highlight that
most big brands are failing to disclose
their supply chain carbon emissions
despite having made big public
commitments to go net zero over the past
couple of years and
and we really want to encourage brands
to be more transparent about this
especially given the urgency of the
climate crisis
well yes and is that purely voluntary at
this stage because i noticed that one
number that really stood out in your
report
is that 95 of brands don't disclose
how much water they use i mean how much
pressure is
on them to be transparent about
statistics like that
yeah unfortunately it's it's not an
obligation on brands to
disclose their water footprint even
though we know that clothing production
uses a huge amount of water in areas
where there is severe
water scarcity but you know you can't
manage what you don't measure
and this is true for lots of other
environmental impacts to the legislation
just
isn't there yet to ensure and require
brands to be open and transparent about
the serious environmental impacts they
are creating in the global fashion value
chain
would you like to see legislation or do
you think that consumers can provide the
pressure
needed you know we need both
we as part of this research process we
we meet with big brands and
whenever we do we ask them what's going
to make them change
and they always tell us that when their
customers ask them to do more
they will and even if they get 100
emails
from their customers this makes a big
difference so whether you shop with
certain brands or not
you should we should all be using our
voice to challenge big brands to do more
about their social and environmental
impacts but tougher legislation is also
crucial
and in the index we've seen a number of
big brands refuse to be transparent over
the past few years of doing this
research
and we know that legislation is the only
thing that's going to make them move
to do the right thing sarah ditty thanks
very much indeed
thank you so much now you're probably
very familiar with the pollution
associated with exhaust
fumes from petrol and diesel cars but
tires could actually be doing more harm
to our health and the environment
now producing tyres in the first place
has a huge climate impact from
deforestation
to the use of fossil fuels to make
synthetic rubber
and as vehicles move around the tires
gradually wear down
producing particulate pollution well
some estimates put that pollution at
around a thousand times
higher than what comes out of a car's
exhaust pipe
now this means more air pollution
especially in cities
and as tyres are used they also produce
tiny plastic
polymers and according to one study
around 28 percent
of micro plastic pollution in the oceans
comes
from tyres tyre pollution is an even
bigger problem for
electric vehicles batteries make them
heavier
putting more pressure on the wheels and
evs have
instant torque meaning much faster
acceleration
wearing towers more quickly well as part
of an initiative to clean up london's
air tfl launched the london freight lab
innovation challenge
sustainable tire developer enso was one
of the winners and they've created what
they say
is a revolutionary new tyre that
increases the range of electric vehicles
and reduces pollution
well their founder and chief executive
gun lawyer ellinson
joins me now so tell us a little bit
about this new tire of yours how does it
differ
from a traditional tire thank you very
much for having us we're very proud here
to be here representing enzo so we've
developed a tire that is energy
efficient
durable and more sustainable than its
counterparts from
the wider tire industry and we're doing
this
basically for the reasons you
demonstrate not only our tire pollution
now more particularly matter in our air
that comes from tailpipes but we also
have this problem that we are simply
increasing the amount of microplastic
pollution that is in our oceans and then
there we breathe
our tires are designed to have more
bio-based and low-carbon raw materials
they're designed to be
more energy efficient so we can also
extend the range
of those electric cars and we're
partnered now with dpd
as part of london freight lab which is
an opportunity to test our tires on
dpd's electric vans
which is an initiative supported by tfl
and the mayor of london
and this not only gives us an
opportunity both to repo reduce
dpd's environmental impact but also
giving their ev
drivers more range for each drive they
have
and what are the challenges been in
developing an environmentally friendly
tire
i think one of the biggest development
hurdles has
actually not been on the entire
development side but simply convincing
people that there's a better way forward
but
we're very fortunate we recently secured
investment from the uk government
actually
and we now actually sourced over 800
private investors
on our crowd cube platform on crowdcube
which is still open and open until
friday
and ultimately it's building these
partnerships that are very different
from how the rest of the tire industry
operates we were very
collegiate we have collaborations now
with major ev tired
so image ev car makers and major ee
fleets
and this is simply a demonstration that
the the industry the wider automotive
industry sees this as a problem and
wants to solve it
while the rest of the tower industry i
would say is fairly reluctant to even
admit it has a problem
good lawyer ellingson thanks very much
indeed thank you so much
well that's it from us for today
tomorrow how using nature can help
tackle the climate crisis
from super sea grass to kelp forests and
oysters
you can find out more tomorrow here on
the daily climate show thanks for
watching
see you then